please welcome reason TVs Ted bellacor  good evening they touch our lives in so  many ways and tonight reason TV  acknowledges those who tell us that if  it looks good tastes good or feels good  it should be illegal the nominees for  nanny of the year are Mick Cornett mayor  of Oklahoma City who sacked the lingerie  football league Burrell Ellis CEO of  DeKalb County Georgia whose department  Sudha man for growing vegetables in his  own yard Louise Fletcher  the city of San Francisco for targeting  pet stores breakfast food bottled water  outdoor smoking soda selling smokes at  drugstores sitting on sidewalks metal  baseball bats movie posters that depict  firearms and happy meals and then Annie  goes to the city of San Francisco this  is San Francisco's first nomination and  award mayor gavin newsom couldn't be  here to accept the nanny but on his bed  mr. mayor mr. mayor check back next  month for more examples of busybodies  minding your own business